kylie jenner is officially a mother of
two
[Music]
the 24 year old gave birth to her second
child with travis scott the two who have
been in an on-again off-again
relationship since 2017 are already
proud parents to three-year-old daughter
stormi webster stormy excited to be a
big sister
she is very excited to be a big sister
we first learned kai was pregnant again
back in august stormy broke the happy
news to grandma kris jenner
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
this is one of the happiest days of my
life
meanwhile a source confirmed the makeup
mogul's pregnancy to et explaining that
kylie loves being pregnant and enjoyed
her last pregnancy out of the public eye
the source added that kylie wanted to
have that same experience this time but
says it was not the best kept secret
what's your biggest pregnancy craving
right now
hmm frozen yogurts and in and out always
so unlike kylie's first pregnancy she
owned this one flaunting her growing
bump on social media and all over new
york fashion week
hey stormy hi the reality star also
opened the door bump on full display for
vogue 73 questions hey kylie before i go
want to ask about your pregnancy
congratulations we're so happy for you
do you have a name picked out
well we need to find out the gender
first and we decided to wait in august a
source told et that having a second
child was always part of kylie and
travis's plan adding that they've quote
always wanted to give stormy a sibling
are you ready to go to mommy's doctor
yeah
honestly you're days away
a couple
as for kylie and travis's parenting
style the source says mom is super
hands-on and dad loves spoiling stormy
according to our source they both plan
on doing the same thing with their new
little one and the whole family is
thrilled about this new addition
[Music]
travis previously opened up to ellen
degeneres about how kylie's mama helped
them through stormy's birth now chris
was here the other day uh your
mother-in-law and she uh said that she
helped deliver stormy that is a that is
a fact that is a fact she was like
walking me through this whole process
it's like this thing called like the
placenta that i've just been hearing
about oh my god so i was like you know i
was fearful of that but i cut the
umbilical cord and you know she held it
down mama kj
um she's the best man we can only hope
that things went a little smoother for
the father of two this last time around
congratulations to the new family of
four
[Music]